Day had broken, and the world as we knew it
fell to pieces.
On every corner of the globe, devastating
rays of sunshine have liquified most of the
human race.
The anomalous phenomenon known as SCP-001
had made the most treasured source of light
and life in the galaxy into the harbinger
of a planetary apocalypse.
In the streets of major cities, which were
once so filled with culture and activity,
melting abominations slithered along the sidewalks
and pavement: a cruel parody of the crowds
and traffic that existed in the world before.
The drought-ravaged wilderness teems with
countless globs of mutant flesh that were
once proud members of the animal kingdom.
Even the plants have wilted into an inert
state, overwhelmed by the sun's energy to
the point of being unable to photosynthesize
it.
There are no planes in the sky anymore, as
no pilot flying on that day could escape the
view of daylight.
The boundless ocean is adrift with boats and
cruise liners occupied by an aimless crew
of amalgamations which even the initial survivors
on the lower decks and within the rooms have
long since been assimilated into.
In the early months of SCP-001 - When Day
Breaks - The Foundation had been able to distribute
rudimentary information on how to shield oneself
from the pervasive rays.
This included a basic but comprehensive how-to
guide on building protective clothing that
would keep out all daylight.
Unfortunately, there is only so much benefit
these solutions can provide - as it has become
too late to save the vast majority of humanity
from their terrible melting fate.
There are sadly limits on what the Foundation’s
foresight and knowledge could do to prevent
a worst-case scenario, and many containment
sites were lost within the first 24 hours
alone.
This means that the veil of normalcy that
SCP Foundation had fought so hard to preserve
has effectively ceased to exist.
Most, if not all, of the accumulated research,
the containment procedures for dangerous anomalies,
and the skilled personnel who were brave and
foolish to think they could keep the world
safe, have met with terrible fates in this
solar-scarred hellscape.
If there was ever an era where the planet
and the universe were stable and under the
control of The Foundation and the 05 council,
that time has passed.
This is not their world anymore, nor is it
a world that can be ruled by any people.
Day has broken, and this is a world of monsters.
Today, two of these monsters, in particular,
find themselves on a collision course.
Both were once extremely dangerous Keter-class
SCPs contained by The Foundation, but through
circumstance and ingenuity, both anomalies
had freed themselves and adapted to the harsh
new reality of the outside world.
They were known as SCP-076-2 Able and SCP-682,
respectively.
Able - now known in the fireside stories of
human survivors as The Black Warrior - had
given himself an armored makeover by forging
his many weapons into a day-proof second skin
straight out of dark fantasy media.
This new edgy gothic look came complete with
a massive sword that Able could use to cleave
straight through any fleshy freakshow he encountered
in the wasteland.
He was a true living legend now - a mysterious
hero, a violent demon, and a force of nature
all at once.
In the day, he stalked through the ruins of
civilization, finding whatever passed for
worthy opponents and cutting them down.
At night, he would seek out those depraved
souls who would prey upon their fellow human
and put them to the sword.
These malefactors had recently become Able’s
favorite vermin to exterminate, since they
always seemed so surprised to be on the receiving
end of an ambush.
Being a survivor in this hellish new world
was difficult enough without the additional
strain of plotting violence, so the ones who
took advantage of the absence of laws and
did so were either exceedingly clever or simply
driven out of their wits by the desire to
inflict harm.
It was through several experiences stomping
out the lingering scum of the Earth that Able
discovered an unfamiliar sense of honor within
himself.
It wasn’t that he grew accustomed to protecting
frail humans from monsters, but rather the
simple fact that a good fight required two
mutually adversarial parties.
Bandits and serial killers could routinely
be counted on to have delusions of grandeur
accompanied by ill intentions, while their
hapless victims could not.
In his own twisted way, Able had accepted
that showing mercy to cowards and weaklings
suited his ends.
After all, if there were no more innocents
left alive there would also be no more reprobates
to menace them.
His quarry needed something to bait them into
emerging from the shadows after all.
Despite having made the most of slim picking,
there was a deep-seated part of Able that
longed for a real challenge.
The Black Warrior wished to face a real monster
like himself again, not the petty brutes and
former human sludge he’d been using as substitutes.
SCP-682 would be an ideal opponent, but he
hadn’t seen the reptile since he was back
in containment.
The two had been made to fight each other
the day before all of this began, and when
during the containment breach that later ensued:
SCP-682 had a makeover of its own.
The highly morphic lizard had tunneled its
way out of Site 19 by evolving large scooping
claws suited for subterranean travel.
Being surprisingly intelligent for its animalistic
shape, 682 had managed to torture the details
of the SCP-001 scenario out of an unlucky
researcher.
While Able had found a way to remain active
during both day and night, SCP-682 had become
a bit more selective in its schedule.
This was possible because the creature had
adapted an internal clock by absorbing the
previously mentioned researcher’s wristwatch.
When the sun was visible in the sky, 682 would
remain dormant underground.
There it could bask in the symphony of suffering
from all the surface-dwelling living things
it could perceive with its enhanced hearing.
It would lie in wait for hours, anticipating
the darkness of nightfall.
Once the sun had set, SCP-682 would emerge
and devour both human and abomination alike.
As a being that harbored pure hatred for all
things that lived, the reptile had far less
discerning criteria for acceptable targets
than Able.
It unleashed its wrath on anything that so
much as got in its way during the nightly
feeding frenzy.
Another way that 682 differed from Able in
its post-apocalyptic way of life was that
it hadn’t been given any evocative nickname
or title.
The reason why was surprisingly simple: SCP-682
hadn’t made its existence known because
any survivors that encountered it never lived
to tell the tale.
It was a surprise to both of them when late
one night, a twist of fate brought the monsters
back together.
SCP-682 had just resurfaced near a small encampment
of survivors and was approaching with the
intention to massacre the panicking humans.
As the hateful reptile drew closer, it noticed
a dark figure lurking at the other side of
the campfire.
It was roughly the size of an average humanoid,
but instead of running and screaming, the
figure stood firm with an enormous sword in
one hand.
One of the fleeing humans cried out, “It’s
the Black Warrior!
We’re saved!”
This amused 682, and it sported a sadistic
grin as it ran towards the survivor and pounced.
While the lizard had wanted to demonstrate
how flimsy the human’s sense of salvation
really was, the opposite took place.
The so-called Black Warrior had intercepted
its jaws and was blocking 682 with only his
sword and all the superhuman strength he could
put behind it.
“Go now, little ant,” The Black Warrior
said.
Following Able’s command, the human fled,
looking back over its shoulder only once to
gaze at the Black Warrior in silent awe.
With that straggler gone, the two monsters
were now completely alone in the camp, both
illuminated by the orange glow of firelight.
They separated and began to circle each other.
Memories of their old rivalry began flooding
back as both of the now-liberated keter-classes
confirmed the identity of the other.
SCP-682 began to laugh as it recognized the
stance of the ancient warrior that had been
such a thorn in its side back in containment.
“Isn’t this priceless?
The proud and merciless Able has become a
defender of those disgusting humans,” SCP-682
said, wearing that horrible smile once again.
“I’m not fighting for them,” The Black
Warrior answered.
He lunged forward, striking a hard blow against
682’s carapace.
The edged sword bounced upward in recoil,
but not without inflicting a deep wound that
682’s regeneration began to work overtime
to repair.
The reptile swiped at Able with its scoop-claws,
then made further use of them by burrowing
into the ground below.
Able knew better than to follow the creature
underground, and he was almost sure that his
scaly nemesis hadn’t yet retreated.
He held his ground and waited, steeling himself
for the moment the creature revealed itself
once more.
As expected, the attack came from directly
below.
SCP-682 breached the surface and snapped its
jaws around one of Able’s armored legs.
Trusting his instincts, the Black Warrior
struck back in the same moment.
His sword stabbed into the reptile’s jaws,
and with a bit of strength, he leveraged his
own leg free.
The armor was dented, but fortunately, there
were no apparent holes left by 682’s fangs.
Able had become accustomed to diligently maintaining
the condition of his armor, as even the smallest
crack could - in the daylight hours - cause
him to lose his solid form forever.
He’d make sure to do a more thorough investigation
later, after the lizard had been put in its
place.
The Black Warrior fought defensively, minimizing
the damage to his armor while timing his strikes
to keep 682 from overwhelming him with sheer
offense.
He could certainly go all out if he chose
to, but that same part of him that wanted
a challenge was willing to prolong the conflict
- especially if he could save himself the
trouble of repairs later.
SCP-682, on the other hand, didn’t care
much for being taken lightly, and was astute
enough to notice when his foe wasn’t as
aggressive as usual.
It had been over a year since the monsters
had fought, but this time there would be no
Foundation personnel to end the fight prematurely.
682 decided that it was time to give the armored
edgelord an onslaught that he couldn’t ignore.
It began to rotate its tunneling claws like
a pair of pneumatic excavators and instantly
showered The Black Warrior with dirt and debris
as it burrowed back into the Earth.
Able could deflect the rocks easily enough,
but the temporary distraction gave 682 time
to dig a large enough cavern beneath Able’s
feet that the ground instantly collapsed beneath
his armored bulk.
Able slid into the growing pit and straight
towards the twin grinding claws of 682.
He tried to use his sword in the ground to
slow his descent, but the earth had been so
thoroughly tenderized by his opponent that
all he accomplished was hastening it.
Just like an antlion larva, SCP-682 had created
a death pit of detritus that was pulling Able
towards the center of the trap.
As if making a whirlpool on land wasn’t
crazy enough for 682, the reptile grew itself
an array of impaling horns across the front
of its face and snout.
Though constructed of flesh and bone, they
had the appearance of serrated blades and
possessed a sharpness and durability capable
of penetrating through Able’s fancy new
suit of armor.
But the Black Warrior wasn’t going to be
defeated so easily, especially not after all
the work he had put in during his latest life
to forge these armaments.
While clutching his giant blade in one hand,
he conjured a new weapon from the shadows:
a harpoon with a strong chain that appeared
already wrapped tightly around his black gauntlet.
Able hurled the harpoon behind him with as
much strength as he could manage in his nearly
prone state, and as he had hoped, its tip
embedded itself in the more stable ground
past the edge of the death pit.
With the spear firmly secured at the other
end, the chain went taught and Able was able
to stop himself just short of falling on SCP-682’s
facial spikes.
With a tremendous one-handed swing that would
be impossible for a mortal man, Able cut through
the middle of the lizard’s organic bayonets,
rendering them practically useless.
His metal boots dug into the silt, and with
all his strength he wrenched himself backwards
towards the top of the pit, tearing the harpoon
free in the process.
With acute precision, he used the chain to
direct the tip of the harpoon between the
fractured bone-blades and into 682’s skull.
The creature bellowed from the sudden pain
and began to dig downward again, but by this
time Able was on stable earth again and was
pulling with all his strength on the other
side of the chain.
SCP-682 burrowed as furiously as it could,
but the harpoon embedded in its head was throwing
off its equilibrium.
Able planted his feet and kept pulling, summoning
more weapons around his feet and legs to keep
them from moving an inch back towards the
pit.
It was a titan’s tug of war, and whoever
gave in would surely be at the mercy of the
other.
Neither monster wavered and the thing that
broke under the strain was the chain itself.
682 tunneled away – harpoon still scratching
its brain – and did not surface again that
night, while The Black Warrior staggered as
he retrieved his now broken length of the
chain.
Able waited for his hated foe to resurface,
but the creature had apparently decided it
was no longer interested in a fight.
And it was just as well, because in the east,
the sun was rising again.
The Black Warrior moved inside one of the
tents that the survivors had left behind,
and prepared for a full examination of his
armor.
While it didn’t last, and no SCP save for
SCP-001 could claim victory here, Able was
grateful to know their still proper adversaries
to fight after the end.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “Could SCP-076 - Able Survive
SCP-001 - When Day Breaks?”
and “SCP-001 When Day Breaks SCP-682”
to see how it all started!